y
[Aplausos]
ah
cada año desde que llegué al colegio hay
un campeonato de fútbol al que todos los
estudiantes de la clase deben participar
este campeonato se divide en tres grupos
por cada grado el primero es conformado
por los mejores en el fútbol el segundo
por los que son medio buenos en el
deporte y el tercero por los peores yo
estoy en el tercero y este profesor dice
de que gracias a este campeonato vamos a
encontrar nuestra pasión interior por el
fútbol
pero acaso todos debemos tener la misma
pasión por el fútbol no era más fácil
escoger a los que sí querían jugar el
deporte y hacer dos o más grupos porque
cambiar lo que nos apasiona a veces los
adultos sin querer hacernos daño
intentan cambiar nuestras pasiones
porque tal vez porque no cumplieron un
sueño o porque
o porque su profesión viene de un legado
es decir que posiblemente sus padres
estuvieron lo mismo y es posible que
hayan dejado esa profesión por algo que
les generará más dinero o por las
opiniones de los demás quienes no
querían que haga esto y si es
comprensible pero es importante
reconocer que nuestros padres siempre
van a querer lo mejor para nosotros y
siempre van a estar ahí para nuestras
decisiones
pero creo que esto pasa porque nos
aferramos a los estereotipos que
mantenemos en el tiempo teniendo en
cuenta que tal vez no funcionen para
siempre
según la real academia española un
estereotipo es una imagen estructurada
aceptada por la mayoría de personas
el escritor murió vélez en su
investigación los estereotipos de género
en jóvenes y adolescentes dice que los
estereotipos están fuertemente
enraizados con la sociedad marcando y
controlando las pautas de comportamiento
de hombres y mujeres diferenciando los
modelos de feminidad y masculinidad a mí
me gusta el diseño es algo que me
apasiona en mi tiempo libre me dedico a
crear diseños de ropa mi primer trabajo
confeccionado fue en diciembre del 2017
cuando hice dos vestidos uno para mi
hermana y otra para mi prima estos
fueron presentados en navidad de ese
mismo año
tal vez les pueda parecer raro que yo
siendo hombre diseñe vestidos
una actividad a la que se necesitan
habilidades de sutileza delicadeza y
estar pendiente de los detalles que son
características que se les han asignado
a las mujeres
en españa en la edad media
la costura era conformada mayormente
solo de mujeres y así es como
comprendemos aferrar 15 cuestionamientos
a pesar que ya han pasado más de tres
siglos
para mí fue un reto poder hablar de este
tema ya que cuando estaba en la
estructura de mi charla mi hermano lo
leyó y dijo que este no era tema para
hablarse ya que la gente pudiera verme
raro o criticarme
sin darme cuenta me estaba condicionando
por un estereotipo de género porque a
nosotros los jóvenes a veces nos da
miedo ser diferentes
ken robinson en su libro el elemento
descubriendo nuestra pasión dice que
para descubrir nuestra pasión se
necesita para pasar por tres niveles el
nivel personal en el que hay que
encontrarnos en nosotros mismos confiar
en nosotros mismos y vencer en nuestros
miedos el nivel cultural y personal que
dice que algunas personas dependen de la
opinión de los demás y eso pudiera ser
un obstáculo al descubrir en nuestra
pasión ustedes creen que merecemos
descubrir nuestra pasión
durante el paso del tiempo hay personas
que se han estado atrayendo a seguir sus
pasiones
actualmente hay mujeres que hacen los
trabajos que antiguamente eran asignados
para los hombres y los hombres hacen
trabajos que antiguamente eran solo para
mujeres pero aún así si a una mujer le
gusta el fútbol la van a ver mal porque
no es una actividad que ella puede hacer
porque solo es una actividad para
hombres
mejor que estudié diseño que estudie
danza que estudie cocina esas esas
profesiones que fueron asignadas desde
un principio para ellos
pero ahora una mujer puede ser mecánica
puede ser abogada incluso policía porque
ellas son capaces de eso así como hay
hombres que cocinan que son amos de casa
que diseñan
creo que debemos seguir propiciando con
los cambios en la sociedad para que ya
no lo veamos como algo extraño o ajeno a
nuestra identidad coco chanel quien fue
una importante diseñadora francesa dice
que para ser irremplazable siempre debe
ser diferente pienso que debemos
respetar las opiniones de cada persona y
de que los adultos nos pueden ayudar a
descubrir nuestras pasiones
enorgullezcan se de ser aquella persona
que tiene el camino hacia lo que le
gusta porque esas personas son las que
transforman los estereotipos de la
sociedad gracias
[Aplausos]